whether you develop apps are a devops
engineer or a programmer learn how to
modernize your legacy Services build
Cloud native applications and lower
costs
with the application modernization
learning path this path was designed to
guide you no matter where you are in
your Learning Journey start at the first
stop if you're new to Google cloud or
jump in at a different stop if you're
enhancing an existing skill set
along the way earn skill Badges and
prepare to become Google Cloud certified
the first few stops will help you learn
the fundamentals of core infrastructure
developing applications with Google
cloud and Cloud run and Google
kubernetes engine
in addition depending on the track you
choose learn about Google SRE culture
architecting with Google cloud and
logging monitoring and observability
Google Cloud offers tracks for cloud
developers and SRE and devops Engineers
choose the track fit for you and your
interests learn from Google Cloud
experts via instructor-led training or
take advantage of the flexibility of
on-demand the choice is completely up to
you
Google Cloud offers multiple modalities
so you can learn how you want to whether
on demand or instructor-led you will
gain access to the same course content
in Labs so you won't miss out on a
hands-on experience practice what you've
learned polish your skills and earn
skill badges
show the world that you and your team
can design develop deploy and monitor
applications on Google Cloud
next up it's time to prepare to become
Google Cloud certified by taking the
instructor-led or on-demand course and
checking out the various guides and
Sample exam questions
once you pass the exam you're officially
a certified professional Cloud developer
or devops engineer on Google Cloud
looking to continue learning or for a
different topic area Google Cloud offers
learning paths spanning across the
solution pillars from beginner to
Advanced this comprehensive learning
path will guide you along your Google
Cloud application modernization Learning
Journey
time to get started